so here's the thing like I did I did a
segment on this last year mm-hmm it's
not about just reading a news source
yeah it's about reading it and then
finding their source and verifying the
information yeah and there was one story
a camera boat is about about Ocasio
Cortez and it was a news article that
referenced a tweet that referenced an
activist blog that referenced an article
and I had to dig down to find the source
and of course it was fake news so it's
like a completely maybe a game of
telephone yep where they slow the story
to finally gets to the media and it's
like they're talking about a purple
elevator when you start out talking
about like a bathtub or something don't
even get me started man okay wait wait
people loved your rants bran
Tim who wants a different story
everybody probably everybody wants a
tear in this guy from NBC because I got
invited the White House he wrote a story
about the people who were invited the
White House and because the narrative
had to be specifically that the only
people invited our fringe wackos this
activist who works for NBC who purports
to be a journalist wrote that Tim Poole
comma who pushed the Seth rich
conspiracy theory and then linked to an
activist blog post that showed a clip of
me out of context and then use that as
evidence and then all of a sudden dozens
of other outlets start just copy and
pasting and so I started hitting them up
saying allow you to get in quick oh it's
working it's it's just it's just cheap
plagiarism it's it's journalism that's
what's called Turner is a turn yes
just turn it now so yeah one outlet saw
NBC and then just copied their article
and rewrote it and then NBC I from MBC
removed the the evidence of what it was
actually because they all started
sourcing each other it's called the guy
from xkc because it's Saito genies is
kind of where it says famine on
Wikipedia where someone will see fake
news okay and then write an APD article
and cite fake news site and then and
then someone from like buzz people see
it Wikipedia and then write on Wikipedia
they claim this and then someone from
deadline will write it's a known fact
that this and then someone on Wikipedia
will say this source you've used this
bunk can you give me a better source and
I'll say yes here's deadlines you can
that's it's not a genius it happens all
the time
so this guy writes a fake story and
here's the best part The Today Show
aired it with a big old picture of me on
NBC
they showed a big old picture of my face
and says this is a guy who's been
pushing the seth rich conspiracy
theories never happened I don't remember
that I've never pushed the Seth rich
conspiracy theory style I was always
skeptical
I always said let's be real stuff like
this never happens you know the
likelihood this is real it was around
the time that kim.com claimed he had
evidence that Seth rich was the
WikiLeaks source and I said mm-hmm well
he's saying it and Fox News just came up
the story confirming that they found
evidence of this I'll give it a 68%
chance
come on guys let's be real stuff like
this never turns out to be true what did
they take a snippet of me being like no
no I'll give it a give it a 60% chance
and then claim Tim Poole pushes the
conspiracy theory by saying the Fox News
story which was definitively posted and
they retracted it later of course it was
well be I thought it was real a lot of
people thought it was real and they were
treck today yeah yeah it was an
investigator guy and and it's like not
only that it's like dude I was in my
living room back when I had like no
YouTube subscribers I had like you know
5000 or whatever and I did a live stream
and I was just someone asked me about it
I'm like I don't know a lot about it but
I saw this story Wow yeah maybe and then
once my channel did well they dubbed
through all of my history and said boom
Tim pulls a conspiracy theory oh we got
him that's the media's game there's
they're vultures they are vultures well
we could the Wikipedia editors weren't
having any of its like someone went in
and tried to add it and then the editors
were like get dis bunk about it and you
know yeah they actually was a huge
debate it was like on your wiki page
whether or not I was a conspiracy
theorist or not and it's like so insane
well the craziest thing to me is how
they use that as a weapon against you
and so it's like if you if you go to any
counter culture or there's a bunch of I
don't know I guess counter culture is
way to say it their Wikipedia pages are
just loaded with complete BS and I'm and
and so I've gone there's a bunch of
journalists who do like news
organizations stuff and like conferences
and I've repeatedly said to them why
won't you call this out yeah give you an
example
BuzzFeed wrote a story man dies
Popeyes and fight over chicken sandwich
never happened they made it up because a
story about two black men fighting the
death of a fried chicken was clickbait
the real story there at Popeyes a guy
cut in line someone called him out the
guy said take it outside and then went
outside he knifed him in the chest real
quick and ran off
nobody was fighting over a sandwich it
was senseless violence this stuff
happens all the time wasn't that was
during the the Popeye chicken sandwich
craze technically you think Popeyes paid
under the table for that well that was a
conspiracy theory really that Popeyes
put out a statement specifically because
they wanted the story to exist that two
men fought to the death of a sandwich
that's how good it was I'm not kidding
I'm not saying it's true but there were
people on social media believing I was
just joking I don't think that's true i
I you want to know what I got no problem
saying this I reached out to Ben Smith
of BuzzFeed okay and I said hey this
story's not real and then he sent me a
quote the police saying they believe
that this had something to do with the
release of the popeyes chicken sandwich
and I said that doesn't prove it's real
yeah in the restaurant at the same time
that was it right and I said to him I'm
vaguely remembering I don't know you
know I may but I remember saying
something to him this was over Twitter
that the dudes family came out and said
nobody his cousin was like ain't nobody
died over our chicken sandwiches his BS
the media's lying and they were lying I
know and didn't you tell me that they're
not even that good I didn't like it I
never tried I didn't like it I like to
clear obvious reasons but but he refused
to correct it
the story's up to this day and so here's
what I did because it still clicks so
News got a comment News guard is the
service that I use yeah yeah actually I
can we can pull up I can show you guys
so this thing right here you'll see the
check mark RealClearPolitics gets a
Green across the board except they don't
label their advertising really well I
mean is that fair yeah they go addresses
I mean I sure whatever whole nutrition
panel
maybe there's articles or whatever well
it's not like clearly different because
it's like a white border so it kind of
glows you know what whatever I mean I
could see here take a look at this I use
this as it's a sort of a credibility
check for myself it's a shield for me
that if you want to claim I'm being
biased by using bad sources I only use
sources when they're certify
by an organization that I find to be
biased okay there are news guards
actually not that bad
but I got an email from them and they
were like you know the trolls are trying
to give us a bad rating whenever they
give a news website a red exclamation
point these sites not all of them will
encourage their readers to go and down
Rank news guard yeah in the App Store
and so I got an email saying because
they're like you know you're like it was
like a general email like supporters
please go help us and I was like okay
and I gave him a 2 out of 5 and I wrote
it's because they give BuzzFeed green
checkmarks across the board except for
the difference between a like they say
they don't handle the difference in
opinion and responsibility I'm sorry
opinion in news responsibly I think they
do and I said they'll give the Daily
wire which has been Shapiro's outlet all
exes because they wrote two or three bad
stories the difference an opinion
because of a difference in opinion and
then they'll give BuzzFeed green
checkmarks across the board even though
BuzzFeed's literally made stuff up the
problem is these organizations by
default believe BuzzFeed to be credible
and so they use BuzzFeed to fact-check
other organizations right when
BuzzFeed's making stuff up exactly and
so here's what happens they say The
Washington Post is is a good credible
source okay so we don't need to actually
so he's what happen let's say I wrote a
story that said that fight over chicken
sandwiches fake news BuzzFeed's line
they'll go to BuzzFeed and they'll say
no buzz because it's true
Tim Poole is lying and they'll give me
the X that's how it works with with the
bias and these systems so you know
BuzzFeed and all these other and like
The Daily Beast has written so much fake
crap I know for I know for a fact
because I was actually on the ground at
several ins events they wrote about and
I'm like they made that up me straight
made stuff up yeah and then I reach out
to the news guard and I say why won't
you call them out I reach out to people
that let the online news Association
none of them will do anything they don't
care and they know it I reached out to
the former editor-in-chief of BuzzFeed
news personally I know Ben I was out I
do out you know I've been to the
BuzzFeed offices and hanging out with
him I saw him on the way to Davos the
World Economic Forum years ago we've
talked he's in one of my videos and so I
hit him up and said you need to correct
this and he said
yeah because the media isn't about
getting the news out there the real news
nots clicks it's about getting people to
their site so that they can make more ad
revenue I'll clarify right I don't think
yeah like it's been a while so to talk
to you didn't directly say like I'm I
refuse to correct her and something he
just said mm the police said it was
related to it we're good and the
headline says sounds like a brush-off in
a fight over a trend basically saying no
and when I reached out to Newt so when I
did that review for news guard yeah I
respond to the email saying just to let
you know you requested it I gave it to
you I gave you a Twitter 5 and here's
why they emailed me back saying I
respect you know you know you've talked
about us but I don't think it's fair and
then I said I like you give Media
Matters green checkmarks across the
board Media Matters it's an activist
organization that it's just basically if
you're conservative or right-wing
they'll lie about you my favorite and
this was funny because Wikipedia the
Wikipedia editors like wigged out on how
insane it was Media Matters wrote that I
pushed a conspiracy theory that ill hand
Ammar Mary may have married her brother
she's the she's a democratic
congresswoman did hear about this but
what they showed on the page was me
looking at the Star Tribune that said
she may have married a man who may her
be her brother
that was their reference so here's the
best part they said Tim Poole falsely
claimed that the Star Tribune claimed
that he'll Hunnam are may have married
her brother and they showed a picture of
me with my face in the corner and the
newspaper for the Star Tribune with the
sentence I was reading I didn't falsely
claim anything I read a sentence off the
newspaper you can literally see it on
your screen and so somebody tried using
the source from Media Matters saying Tim
was a conspiracy theorist on Wikipedia
and they were like I clicked that and
they're claiming that a paper he read
was a false attribution but they shoved
the paper he was reading yeah exactly
that's how insane they are and they get
green checkmarks as credible that's news
guard because so why I mean you started
by saying you use news guard because you
want to have your stuff checked but it's
clear to me that they are biased
so how do you know that it's even worth
using that if a news guard wants to come
to me and like give me a right checkmark
or whatever yeah excuse me I'm gonna
laughs I'm gonna black why bro
I only use cites you've approved uh-huh
that's funny so what what the only
reason because it sounds like their
check marks mean nothing
people like Media Matters using that you
know smear against me okay that's how
they weaponize it they try to claim you
know you're pushing a fake news websites
like don't look at me man if news guard
says it's good I use it so I I used the
Center for Immigration Studies as a
source once okay and a bunch of
progressives started claiming as using
alt-right propaganda and I'm just like
don't look at me man News Guard said
they're certified factual and correct
end of story
don't care brush it off the perfect
scapegoat it's not me it's it's they
profess Trillo it's true I know I don't
know what I'm saying thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you